welcome to another Private Pilot ground
lesson from free pilot training I'm J
hey you
who me
yeah you what do you think you're doing
a fly did you check the notems why would
I need to do that I'm doing patterns man
bro you need to check the nodems
each pilot in command shall before
beginning a flight become familiar with
all information available concerning
that flight
you need to check the not ones man relax
I'll I'll check them I'll check them
[Music]
as you just saw one of the requirements
before beginning a flight is to become
familiar with all available information
concerning that flight now I discussed
this rig in quite a bit of detail in
some of my other lessons but today I
want to talk about some other
information that concerns every flight
and aircraft nodems and the chart
supplement let's start with the chart
supplement since that's a relatively
easy topic back in the day this thing
used to be called the airport facility
directory but that was so 2016. times
have changed and now we call it the
chart supplement
now I had a little bit of fun at the
beginning of this video but I think
every season pilot has forgotten to look
at the chart supplement before flying at
least once in their career I have to
admit that I've done it but that's not a
good habit to get into because every
Airfield is a little bit different in
some way and you don't want to be caught
off guard by something at the Airfield
that you're flying into
the VFR sectional is an awesome tool and
it has almost all the information that
you need to fly into an Airfield but the
chart supplement is the official spot
where you can find the most complete
information on an airport or an Airfield
now this video would be super long and
boring if I just broke down every line
in the chart supplement but let's take a
look at some of the stuff in here that I
think you're going to find useful
as you've probably noticed some of the
airfields in here have a ton of
information then some of them have very
little
as you can see bigger airfields like
Tulsa International will sometimes even
include an Airfield drawing and all
kinds of stuff while airfields like
Vanita Municipal have very little
information but there's also not much to
know about that Airfield either except
for the fact that they have the world's
largest McDonald's and it's within
walking distance of the runway not sure
whether didn't mention that here I think
that's pretty important but anyway let's
take a look at a few more things you
should know when you look at this thing
first things first we have the airport
identifier right here and that's nice
because if you're using a GPS for
navigation you're going to need that
information as you can see Tulsa has two
this one is the FAA code and from what
I've been told from some of the ATC
controllers I've talked to this is the
code that they'd really like to get from
you when you call them up and request a
clearance or flight following the second
code is what we call an Iko and the main
difference is that this one has a
country code in front of it K is a
country code for the lower 48
continental U.S if for some reason
you're flying in another country that
first letter would be different it's
actually a p if you ever go up to Alaska
and fly up there
but anyway next we have the distance and
direction of the airport from the main
part of town
as you can see Tulsa International is
about five miles Northeast of town and
this is really handy to know especially
when you're flying at night because
airports can be kind of tricky to spot
in the dark okay here's another one
that's handy to know
any times that you see here on the chart
supplement are given in Zulu time
so they tell you right here what the
conversion to the local time is let's
say that we're in daylight savings time
in that case all we need to do is
subtract five hours from the times that
we see here in the chart supplement so
if I needed to convert these times right
here into local time I could subtract 5
from them to get a local time of 5 a.m
to 1am but we're not quite done yet
check out this little plus plus symbol
right here if you read the note about
this up at the front of the chart
supplement what you'll find is that the
plus plus symbol means that during
periods of daylight savings time the
times you see here or the effective
hours of operation will be one hour
earlier so these times are actually 4
a.m to midnight remember this little
plus plus thing you're probably going to
need that at some point
next we have the center point of the
Airfield this is the center most point
of all the runways when you put the
letters KTUL into your GPS this is where
your GPS is going to take you and that's
important to know especially when you
start working on instrument stuff
now we've got all the different runways
listed right here and this is where
you'll find some of the most important
information here in the chart supplement
once again I'm not going to go over all
the stuff you'll find in here if you
ever see anything weird you can look up
at the front of the chart supplement at
the legend which is a huge Treasure
Trove of information but let's go ahead
and look at a couple things that I think
you should know
first we have the runway size as you can
see Runway one eight left three six
right is 150 feet wide and 10 000 feet
long so I think you've got plenty of
Runway today for the old Skyhawk now one
important thing to keep in mind is that
this 10 000 feet you see here is
literally the first brick of the runway
all the way to the last brick of the
runway this includes displaced
thresholds so if you need more details
on runway length check the declared
distance information down here here we
can see what kind of visual approach
Lighting systems they have as you can
see they've got Pappy's here on 1 8 left
and those bring us in on a Glide slope
of 2.75 degrees now you might be
thinking who cares but this is actually
really handy to know because if the
Glide slope is more than three degrees
that can indicate that there's an
obstacle at the approach into that
Runway this THC here stands for
threshold Crossing height this is saying
that if you follow the pappies or vassi
you'll cross the Threshold at about 56
feet and that can be handy to know if
there's an obstacle or something near
the approach into the runway that you're
concerned about especially at night if
you haven't flown too much at night
you're going to find that it can be
difficult to tell where the trees and
other obstacles are when you're on final
this little tidbit of information can
really give you some peace of mind
now as you probably already know
standard traffic patterns are left-hand
turns because of that you won't find
anything in the sectional or the chart
supplement if the runway has a left hand
pattern but if the runway has a right
hand pattern not only will you find it
in the VFR sectional at the very bottom
of the information block but you'll also
find it here as well
as you can see Runway 36 right here at
Tulsa has a right hand traffic pattern
another thing that I think is worth
mentioning is this right here
as you can see this Airfield has
something called an arresting gear
system now these things really don't
concern you until they do and the reason
I say that is because this is basically
a cable that can be raised to catch
fighter aircraft if they have an
emergency and they're not going to have
enough runway for some reason well as
you can imagine if you land on that in
your system when the barrier is raised
it will literally tear your landing gear
completely off now most kinds of
barriers these days are retractable and
this is one of those retractable
barriers and 99.9 percent of the time
the barrier is going to be down and the
tower will let you know if it is up
until they accidentally forget to tell
you well you can avoid this problem
altogether one of two ways first you can
look here and see that the barrier is
one thousand five hundred feet down the
runway and you can just land Beyond it
it doesn't show the barrier on this
diagram but as you can see it does show
it here on the airport diagram in the
back of the chart supplement that's what
this weird looking cattywampus arrow
thing is and like I said if I know that
I can just land past the barrier and I
don't have to worry about it at all or I
can just ask the tower they're the ones
that raise and lower those things so
they're going to know whether it's up or
down hey Tower I just want to confirm
that the barrier is down and disengaged
the barrier is down and disengaged that
only took me like two seconds to check
and now I still have landing gear in
case I need it next we have the service
section this is kind of nice so I don't
fly all the way up here and then realize
they don't have the fuel I need they've
even got the hours here so I don't show
up late and have to pay that hundred
dollar fee just to get fuel okay here's
an interesting one this airport actually
has noise abatement procedures this
isn't really a huge deal for small
piston-driven aircraft but in a larger
more powerful aircraft these are really
important to follow people get kind of
mad when you do low passes in loud
aircraft over their homes
I guess they don't like the sound of
freedom
okay this is an important section as you
can see there's a lot of good
information in here but the most
important information is right here this
airport is a big airport so it's
attended continuously but at some
airfields that's not always the case
here at this airport it's only attended
from 1200 Zulu to zero 400 Zulu once
again let's say that we're in daylight
savings time so I'll subtract five hours
from these times and once again we've
got this little plus plus emblem here so
the operating hours are one hour earlier
than what we're reading here for
daylight savings time
so this airport is only attended from 6
a.m to 10 pm local time now don't let
this confuse you this is not necessarily
when the tower is in operation you'll
find that information down here and as
you can see there's some really
important information down here as well
first if we want to sound cool on the
radios we need to refer to these guys as
Riverside tower now this might not seem
really important to you but this can
actually save your bacon if you
accidentally dial in the wrong frequency
on your radio which actually happens way
more than you might think well if
someone hears me calling for Riverside
tower on the wrong frequency and they
know the right frequency they can say
hey jackwagon you need to be on 120.3
there's no doubt who you're trying to
contact anyway in addition to that we've
got the frequencies here for the tower
and boom there's the tower's operating
hours okay so it looks like they operate
from 1300 to 0-400 Zulu so let's see
that'd be 8 AM to 11 p.m but once again
we've got this little plus plus emblem
and this is during daylight savings time
so the tower operates from 7 A.M to 10
pm local
anytime outside those hours The Fill
reverts to non-towered operations well
what ctap frequency do they use when
that happens too easy just look up here
at the communications line and it looks
like you make your untowered radio calls
on 120.3 that just so happens to be the
same frequency as the tower but that's
not always the case now don't let this
Unicom frequency over here confuse you
it seems like 75 percent of Pilots out
there don't even know what a Unicom
frequency is this can sometimes be the
same frequency as the ctap but that's
not always the case
basically a Unicom just means that you
can request services like traffic
advisories weather advisories or even
fuel from the FBO or the airport
attendant and that can be really handy
if you're just trying to make a really
quick fuel stop and get back on the road
Christensen Jet Center this is Skyhawk
3148 x-ray what's up 48 x-ray yesterday
I just landed here at Riverside and I'm
taxing over it's
fueled that'd be great
Roger foreign
now one other thing you might be
wondering is what kind of airspace am I
flying in now that the tower has shut
down now we can tell by looking at the
VFR sectional that Riverside Tower is
usually in class Delta airspace and we
can also tell by this big beautiful C
right here that this is a c-tap
frequency as well as the tower frequency
but what if you want to know what this
airspace turns into when the tower
closes well for that you'd have to look
back at the chart supplement take a look
here at the airspace line it looks like
the class Delta Services only operate
from 1300 Zulu to zero 400 Zulu once
again that'd be 7 AM local to 10 pm
local
it looks like all other times that class
Delta airspace reverts to class golf
now it's important to note that when an
airfield like this has a tower that only
operates part-time the airspace does not
always revert to class golf the only way
to know exactly what happens to that
airspace is to look in the chart
supplement that's why it's so important
to know this information okay when it
comes to airport information there's one
other thing that you need to know that's
super important and that's who owns the
airspace above that airport this is
important because if you want to use
radar services like flight following or
if you want to go into airspace that
requires two-way radio communications
then you need to know who to get a hold
of and the official place to get that
information is right here in the chart
supplement
okay so if you want to use radar
Services the easiest way to find that
frequency is to look for this little r
right here
next to that you could see a couple
different things if you're close to a
bigger airport that has radar services
like a class Charlie airport a class
Bravo airport or a tersa you'll
typically find that the airspace is
operated by approach or departure
control
here at Riverside you can see that Tulsa
approach owns this airspace so if I want
to get flight following these are the
guys I need to call on the radio but
which frequency should I use this isn't
rocket science as you can see that
depends on where you are in relation to
the Airfield according to this note if
my bearing from Riverside is anywhere
from 175 degrees all the way to 355 I
should be using 134.7
if my bearing is 356 to 174 then I
should use 119 or 0.85 now you don't
need to pull out your protractor if
you're right here on one of these lines
focus on flying the airplane use the
frequency that makes sense to you and if
they want you on the other frequency
they'll send you over there with that in
mind some airfields are not in a
terminal area and that just means that
they aren't close to one of these big
radar facilities at one of these bigger
airfields but just because you aren't
near an approach or departure facility
that doesn't mean that radar is not
available by the way approach and
departure services are usually operated
out of the same facility
we call this a traycon facility which
stands for terminal radar approach
control that's a freebie but anyway
sometimes you'll find that the airspace
above your Airfield is actually Center
controlled instead of being owned by a
tracon
as you can see the airspace over this
particular field is owned by Fort Worth
Center
and you probably already noticed this
but their frequency is going to be 128.4
this is important to know for two
reasons first center control radar is
very limited
these facilities do have high power
radar systems that work fantastic but
they can be limited by line of sight
because the facilities are usually
farther away from where you're going to
be flying this means that if you don't
have adsb a lot of times you'll have to
climb up pretty high before they can see
you on radar because of that you need to
be extra descriptive when you tell them
where you are
Center Skyhawk 3148 x-ray Skywalk 3148
x-ray Fort Worth center Fort Worth
Center Skyhawk 3148 x-ray I am 10
nautical miles to the south of
Weatherford Stafford Oscar Juliet Alpha
3500 climbing 5 500. I'd like to pick up
flight following to Lawton Airport Lima
Alpha Whiskey Scouts three one four
eight x-ray radar contact one one miles
south of Weatherford Stafford
squawk0123 altimeter
2904-0123 altimeter 2994 Skyhawk three
one four eight x-ray notice how
descriptive I was with that radio call
even with a good radio call because
Center controllers own a lot of airspace
they may still ask you to ident no big
deal just hit that ident button and
that'll help them find you a lot easier
by the way if he says I didn't and
doesn't give you a heading altimeter or
a squawk you don't need to respond just
hit the ident button it's not a huge
deal to say something when the radios
aren't busy but sometimes adding extra
stuff can really clog up the radios
the other thing is that our radios can
also be limited by line of sight and
because of that sometimes you'll have to
climb up a little bit higher to get a
hold of a center controller but
sometimes using a different frequency
can help solve that problem as well now
one other thing I want to mention is
that some airfields don't show this
little r in this case you can still find
out who owns the airspace above the
airport by looking at this little line
that says clearance delivery notice here
at Veneta Municipal Kansas City Center
owns the airspace Above This Airfield
but they don't give you a frequency for
some reason that's because the frequency
you use is probably going to depend on
where you're going now this is
specifically designed for IFR Pilots but
there's nothing wrong with using this to
get yourself set up for flight following
as a VFR pilot all you have to do is
call this number right here just keep in
mind when you call this number this is
going to be a very rigid phone call it's
going to feel a lot like talking on the
radio tell the guy on the other end
everything you'd tell the ground
controller right before taking off from
a towered Airfield
good morning this is Charles from Kansas
City Center yes sir I'm going to be
taking off from Bonita municipal airport
here in about 30 minutes that's hotel04
and I'll be flying Skyhawk 3148 x-ray
I'd like to pick up flight following if
possible to Joplin Regional Airport
Juliet Lima November final altitude will
be 5500. okay Skyhawk 314 at x-ray
maintained via far to Juliet Lima
November on departure fly Runway heading
I may maintain 5500 contact Kansas City
Center on
128.640231 VFR to Juliet Lima November
fly Runway heading common maintain 5500
128.6
squawk0231
skyhawk3148 x-ray 3148x3 be back correct
we'll talk to you in a few minutes
sounds great thank you
well that guy seemed a little bit like a
tool bag now I know that there's a bunch
of other ways that you can snag the
frequency for these guys but I thought
you might enjoy seeing another option
that you might not be used to seeing
this is the way that you're going to be
picking up IFR clearances out of these
small airfields once you get your
instrument rating so if you already know
how to do that you're one step ahead of
everyone else let's look at one more
thing you should know about the chart
supplement
in addition to all the information we
just discussed the chart supplement also
gives us details on different activities
that happen on or in the vicinity of an
airport this can be anything from glider
operations to parachute jumping a bunch
of different stuff now if you've ever
looked at the VFR sectional you've
probably seen a symbol like this on
there and as you might have guessed this
little parachute lets you know that
parachute operations of some kind happen
there on a regular basis
but if we want to know when and where
that happens we need to look in the
chart supplement now a lot of that type
of information will be in the remarks
section of each Airfield but parachute
jumping information has its own section
here in the supplement
if you ever have trouble finding
something in here just be sure to look
at the table of contents up at the front
of the book and as you can see parachute
jump information is kind of close to the
back
as you might have already noticed in
order to decipher this thing you kind of
have to use it backwards I'm guessing
that this parachute symbol is roughly 30
miles Northeast of the Little Rock
airport so we'll find the Arkansas
section in here and it looks like there
are two possible Drop Zones right in
that area
I just so happen to know that these are
actually the same place they're just
surveyed a little bit differently so the
military can use them in different ways
so let's look at the first one here as
you can see the name of this particular
area is called blackjack Drop Zone it's
exactly 33 miles Northeast of Little
Rock at a bearing of 0 1 0 from the Four
tag notice here that the chart
supplement gives us the maximum altitude
that these drops should be occurring if
you read the notes you'll notice that
these altitudes are usually in MSL
unless otherwise noted as you can see
the max drop altitude here though is
actually 3000 feet AGL so if we want to
avoid getting into a dangerous situation
we need to fly at least four thousand
feet MSL preferably higher then we can
see over here when those drops typically
take place now you probably notice that
these are some pretty generic times if
you want more detail on those times you
have to check the nodums which we'll
discuss more here in just a minute but
before we move on I'd like to take a
second to show you some of the things
that you could potentially see in
Parachute areas like this trust me you
do not want to be flying in these areas
when these operations are in progress
yes it's cool to watch but do you know
which direction these guys are coming
from when they make these drops probably
not please pay attention and try to
avoid these areas during the hours of
operation that'd be terrible for someone
or something to land on top of your
Cessna 172.
mind there's a lot more stuff in the
chart supplement than what I just
discussed I highly recommend taking a
minute today to skim through that thing
and see what's in there
there are air filled diagrams in the
back and all kinds of other handy tools
that you might like to try and use on
your next flight but let's go ahead and
move on the next thing we need to
discuss today are the nodums in order to
be familiar with all available
information concerning that flight you
need to check the node before you go fly
and every time you go fly right now you
might be thinking could grief how many
things do I need to look at before I can
go fly now I got to look at these dumb
nodem things that's stupid
here's an acronym that I like to use to
remember all the basic stuff that must
be checked anytime I go fly once
first you got to check the weather
then if you're going to be flying IFR or
you want to file a VFR Flight Plan you
need to activate that flight plan
but in addition to that you really need
to have an alternate plan anytime you go
fly
this is required when the weather's bad
during IFR flight but it's a really good
habit to get into for VFR Pilots as well
then you've got the nodems you've got to
check those
next we've got told which stands for
takeoff and Landing data according to 91
103 you are required to know how much
runway you have and how much runway you
need then we've got SIDS and stars and
those are instrument things so don't
worry about those right now okay just so
you're not confused the acronym nodum
stands for notice to air missions it
actually used to be short for notice to
Airmen but that was way too sexist so we
got rid of that name but that's exactly
what these are their notices to Pilots
ooh we should have gone with no Taps
that sounds way cooler anyway these
things let us know about things that
could potentially affect our flight they
can tell you when there's a new tower
near the runway they can tell you that
the VOR on the field is broken or they
could even tell you about a big herd of
elk that have been hanging out there on
the field the possibilities are endless
and as you can see checking these before
you go fly can really save you a ton of
pain and Agony plus it'd be a lot cooler
if you did
according to the aim the nodum system
provides Pilots with time-critical
aeronautical info nation that is
temporary or information to be published
on aeronautical charts at a later date
or information from another operational
publication
so these nodums are either temporary or
they're letting you know about something
that has changed that's going to be
permanent and these things can actually
be created and pushed out up to seven
days before they're active so if you
ever plan on going on a long trip or
anything that can be kind of nice to
keep in mind as well
now in general there are four types of
nodums but the only ones that really
concern you as a Private Pilot are these
two right here nodem DS and FDC nodems
FTC nodums are used when regulatory or
governmental type information needs to
be disseminated
these types of modems include temporary
flight restrictions changes to
aeronautical charts and other stuff like
that
so if some big Wing Company came in and
threw up a big wind turbine right here
they won't actually change the charts
until at least the next cycle
so to tell you about this thing they'll
create an FDC nodem for that until the
chart can be updated
nodemds are domestic nodums and that
just means that these are basic nodems
that can affect any Airfield or
navigational Aid in the National
airspace these can let you know about
all kinds of different activities that
are happening on the Airfield that can
be anything from those parachute or
glider operations that we were talking
about earlier to mowers operating on the
Airfield remarks power is operating on
the Airfield anyone else here know what
a mower is I surely don't anyway these
can tell you when the visual navigation
AIDS like the vasses or the pappies are
broken or even the radio nav AIDS like
vor's they can even create nodemds to
point out big nodems that are super
important like tfrs or big air shows and
once again some of the most important
nodems to pay attention to can be
nodemds because these are the ones that
are going to tell you about the airport
and Runway closures and other stuff like
that that you definitely want to know
now before I talk about how to decipher
these little boogers I want to take a
look at how to find the nodems you
actually need for your flight this in
and of itself can be kind of tricky but
let's break it down Barney style think
about where you're going to be flying
first we need to get the nodems for our
departure Airfield then we need to get
the nodems for our arrival Airfield and
we also need to get all the nodems along
our route of flight
departure and arrival notems are pretty
self-explanatory all you need to do is
grab the airport identification code for
those airports the enroute nodems are
the tricky ones to find because you need
to know what airspace you're going to be
operating in now if you're going to be
flying through airspace surrounding a
big Airfield I would definitely look at
the notice for that airport as well but
for the rest of the airspace you're
going to be operating in there's
something else you got to know
these are called artcc nodems most
Pilots refer to these as centernotems
and when you think about enroute modems
these are the main ones you should be
thinking about because these will tell
you all the big stuff in that Center
controlled airspace these nodems can let
you know about restricted areas that are
active and they can tell you about nav
AIDs that are broken along your route of
flight and they can even give you
specific details on those airdrops that
I was talking about earlier in the chart
supplement okay now that you know that
let's jump on the fa's nodem website and
find the nodems we actually need for
today's flight I'll put a link for this
website in the description in case you
need it for later there's also a link
down there if you'd like to support this
channel by purchasing some free pilot
training gear if that interests you at
all
[Music]
okay let's go ahead and agree with this
thing that we didn't actually read and
now that we're here we need three things
we need the airport identifier code for
our departure airport the code for our
arrival airport and we also need the
identification code for any airspace
that we're going to be flying in
and probably the hardest part about
getting these notems is knowing which
code to use for these in-root nodems now
if you have four fly it's super easy to
get this code you just touch the
airspace that you're going to be flying
in then as you can see Memphis Center
owns all this airspace and if I zoom out
I can see how much airspace they
actually own
if I click over here on details it'll
actually display the code right here
so the identifier code for Memphis
Center is kzme now someone from the FAA
is watching this I'm begging you right
now please please please put these codes
in the chart supplement yes I know that
they're easy to grab off of foreflight
and it is possible to find maps like
this by Googling artcc boundary map but
it'd be really nice to have these codes
in the chart supplement I mean you guys
put the Iko for each airport in there
for crying out loud anyway if you're not
using forefly I highly recommend taking
a screenshot of this map you legally
need to use these codes to get your
enroute nodems by the way I know that
there are a bunch of cfis that watch
these videos I'd really appreciate you
guys sharing your techniques for finding
these codes for those students who don't
have foreflight I'm a four flight baby
so I can't figure out where else to get
these codes anyway off my rant let's go
back to the faa's nodem website now with
the exception of the artcc chart this
nodem website is pretty decent all you
have to do is type in those codes that
we just mentioned and since this is a
year Us site we don't need to put the K
at the beginning of these codes so let's
see we'll say we're departing out of
North Little Rock which is Ork
then we're going over to Conway which is
cxw then we'll grab the lit nodem since
we're going to be operating underneath
the airspace
then we'll grab the Memphis internodeums
by typing in zme now one other type of
nodem that I like to check on here are
the GPS nodems if you're flying VFR you
really don't have to check these but
it's nice to know when there's going to
be a bunch of satellites out of service
okay now we have a few things that we
need to comb through but don't worry
this is way easier than it looks the key
to solving this riddle is in the aim in
section
5-1-3 whether you're looking at these
nodems in this really simple format from
the faa's website or if you're looking
at the actual node and printout like
this it's important to keep in mind that
every node must have a keyword and a
location identifier in it remembering
that will help you quickly determine
whether or not a specific nodum applies
to you
before we get into that here's something
kind of new this isn't really a nodem
but sometimes you'll see these little
graphic depictions of the Airfield that
can give you an idea about some of the
upcoming construction projects that they
may have going at the airport this can
help make some of these nodems a little
bit easier to read anyway let's decipher
some notems now if you have a name
available I highly recommend turning
over to 5-1-3 in here there's a great
little table that shows you some of the
keywords that'll really help you with
these things
okay so check out this little guy this
little d right here is telling you that
this is a nodem d so this is not a
regulatory nodem this is just a basic
nodem that's telling us something that
we might want to know that's happening
in the National airspace next we have
our location as you can see this nodem
is for lit that's atoms field and I
picked that because we're going to fly
underneath their class Charlie to get
over to Conway
so I'm not concerned about every nodem
over there I'm mostly concerned about
airspace and a few other things all
right here we have the nodem number I
have never needed this but in case you
do I guess it's there for you next we
have the keyword notice the keyword in
this notem is Communications
if I'm going to be getting flight
following this might concern me if not I
might just move right on and continue
down the notem list but let's say I'm
going to be using my radios today so
we'll take a closer look at this guy as
you can see this modem starts on May 1st
2023 at zero 400 Zulu and it's a
permanent nodem so they either don't
know when this is going to get resolved
or they don't have plans to fix whatever
this is
next we have the condition this says com
remote com Outlet
255.4 U slash S okay what the heck is
this U slash S
here's where you can dig out this table
from the aim that gives you more details
on that but as you might have guessed U
slash S stands for unserviceable so
255.4 is broken well that might be kind
of nice to know if you're flying a C-130
because that's a military UHF frequency
for the flight service station but no
one else cares so let's see what's next
ah no Little D here this must be an FDC
nodem and it looks like our location is
zme so this is a center nodem and the
key word is airspace well I'm kind of
concerned about airspace today there
happens to be a couple restricted areas
directly north of the field where I'm
taking off from
so I'm going to be watching for those
when I'm looking through these anyway it
looks like this notem has been around
since 2017 and this one's permanent as
well now there is something you should
be aware of about permanent nodums when
you go fly you're going to get really
familiar with these but you still need
to glance at them to make sure they
haven't changed and if you call a flight
service station to get your notems they
will actually lead these out of the
briefing if you get your notems that way
so if you fly into a new Airfield you
really need to take a look at the nodems
even if you do get a briefing from the
FSS anyway let's go back to this nodem
airspace uas okay let's figure out what
uas stands for with our chart unmanned
aircraft system okay so at this lat long
or 5.2 miles Northeast of Vicksburg
someone could be flying a drone up to
400 feet AGL okay well I'm not going to
be operating anywhere near there so I
don't care next okay we have lit and the
keyword is procedure procedure changes
are usually adjustments to instrument
approaches and that sort a thing let's
see yep it looks like they made some
changes to the rnab minimums over there
that doesn't concern me at all today
looks like we actually have a few of
those so let's get down here to this zme
one okay so the key word here is root it
looks like they made a change to one of
the meas over on Victor 71 that's an IFR
route so that doesn't really concern us
today either looks like we actually have
a few routes on here with some changes
once again we're VFR so I don't care
about any of those ooh airspace though
that could be important RDO altimeter
unreliable so this particular code isn't
in the aim but this actually stands for
radio altimeter or radar altimeter this
is the infamous 5G modem everyone's been
super concerned about yeah 5G is a
serious problem when it comes to these
things it's actually causing GPS issues
too but for some reason we're more
concerned about having fast internet for
our kids watching those dumb tablets 24
7 then aircraft safety but let's get off
that topic before I start losing too
many subscribers
okay another route ah obstruction
obstruction Tower lighting U slash S so
there's a light bulb burned out on this
Tower I could look at the exact location
of this but I don't care I'm not flying
anywhere near MSL which is Northwest
Alabama Regional another route okay
another airspace May 2021 to January
2024 we may have a winner oh someone's
doing aerobatics here
it looks like within a one mile radius
of this location here
this is a radial DME so it's on the 297
radial from Nashville at 25 miles yup
doesn't apply
next we have another procedure at lit op
cxw that's our arrival airport the key
word is Aerodrome which is another word
for airport and looky there another 5G
modem actually the next two is the same
nodum over Adams Field and North Little
Rock thanks 5G I don't know what we ever
did without you
okay more Memphis Center stuff airspace
ah this could be important the dates are
applicable airspace
r3702b active 10 000 feet to flight
level two two zero so it looks like we
had three active restricted areas now if
you want to save a little time don't
play this game of where's the restricted
area the fastest way through these
things is to look at your route of
flight and see what airspace is nearby
first if I zoom in here you can see that
there are two restricted areas along my
route of flight but it's r2403 Alpha and
r2403 Bravo and these ones in the nodums
are nowhere near where I'm going to be
flying today so I couldn't care less
about them okay another route don't care
procedure don't care another route ah
looks like there are a couple aerodrum
nodums over at lit once again these are
referring to the Airfield and I'm not
actually flying over there oh shoot the
wind cone over there is not standard I'm
not sure what we're gonna do cancel the
flight no we're not going to do that if
I was going to be flying over there I
might be concerned about these taxiway
closures but I'm not so I don't ah
here's a key word we haven't seen yet
NAB Aid now for today the only one I
might be concerned about is the vortac
over there if I was wanting to use it
but it looks like it's the ILS that's
down over on four left and two two right
so I think we're going to make it
okay there's another Aerodrome notome
that I don't care about oh Services
what's that
Runway four left rvr unserviceable
rvr stands for Runway visual range and
this is kind of an interesting
Contraption this basically shoots a
laser beam out that can give us a
visibility and feet right there at the
runway
don't worry you'll learn more about this
when you go for your instrument rating
okay more Aero drum stuff over lit that
I really don't care about another nav 8
over there once again it's not the
vortex so I'm not too worried about it
there's another Tower with a bowl burned
out wow they really need to hire someone
to change those bulbs out not going to
be me ah okay here are my GPS notems
looks like we've got a couple PRN things
unserviceable if you look it up PRN
stands for pseudo random navigation
basically all these are saying is that
the number 22 and the number 28
satellites aren't sending out a good
signal on some GPS systems you can
actually type these numbers in and tell
you GPS that you don't want to receive a
signal from either one of these guys
that allows you to treat these
satellites kind of like you do your
in-laws
[Music]
just kidding you didn't hear that from
me anyway some GPS systems will actually
exclude those bad satellites for you
once again this is going to be more
important for instrument stuff
next we have another bulb that's burned
out ah here we go this is an interesting
one it's another airspace nodem for
Memphis center it's valid starting on
May 1st through May 22nd and it's
affecting adsb
we could click on this to get the full
lat long but I'm not super worried about
it I'm not operating in any airspace
where I even need adsb today so who
cares okay looks like we have a few more
Towers here with burned out bulbs now I
do think it's worth mentioning that
these might be a little bit more of a
concern at night
if I'm going to be flying at night I may
want to take a closer look at where
these are up more airspace airdrop ah
let's see where this is looks like from
the lit Vortec it's a bearing of 338 at
33 miles and it goes to the 017 radio at
35 miles
now if we pull out the old plotter as
you can see this is that airdrop area
that we were talking about earlier so
they're telling us here that this is a
roughly three mile corridor from here to
here and the times you can expect for
this is from 1400 to 0-500 Zulu and
these times are going to be a lot more
accurate than what you see in the chart
supplement now check these next three
modems out every single airport on our
list today has one of these These are
called pointer nodems notice the letter
zme in here as you can see these are
pointing to that nodem that we just
talked about that's kind of weird they
must think that nodem is really
important or something
now they don't do this with all nodems
so you need to check the end root notems
every time still but this is something
nice to look out for
okay more airspace looks like another
drone operator out there then we have a
couple more burned out bulbs more drones
ah what's this nav GPS may not be
available within a 264 mile radius of
these areas
wow that one seems important
let's save this one for last looks like
we have a couple more airspace notems in
here and then it looks like the Meridian
mowers are going to be active those are
nowhere near where I'm going to be
flying today but here's a pop quiz
can I go in there since they're active
yes you can as a VFR aircraft but would
it be smart not really but it's totally
legal okay we've got a couple more drone
operators here ah another restricted
area let's see I had to double check but
nope I'm only concerned about 2403 Alpha
and 2403 Bravo today
so I'm not concerned about this one
either
now that's the last nodem but let's talk
about that pesky GPS modem we just
mentioned a second ago
now I know on VFR so I probably don't
actually care but I'm just curious now
sometimes you might want to print the
nodems and this website allows you to do
that if you want let's scroll up here
and click on this little PDF thing and
download these
I know I know these are really painful
to look at when they're in this raw form
but just remember what I told you look
for the keyword and the location
let's find that pesky GPS nodem looking
here it has the keyword GPS all over the
place in here
then it has our location of zme so now
let's see where this thing is it looks
like it's centered around this lat long
here I'm lazy though so I think I'll
just use this radial DME
this notem is saying that at flight
level 250 this thing is causing problems
within a 216 mile radius at 10 000 feet
they're seeing issues at 151 miles then
at 4000 the range is 106 and at 50 feet
AGL your GPS could have issues within 54
nautical miles
now my curiosity is peaked so I threw
this point in four flights get a closer
look at what this could possibly be
causing this GPS anomaly
interesting this dot is within a half a
mile of a radio tower of some sort would
this be a 5G Tower there's really no way
to be sure unless we zoom in and enhance
the footage
foreign
you should have seen the look on your
face I'm sorry about that but it does
make you wonder doesn't it and while
this might not be a huge deal if you're
flying VFR you can imagine how
concerning it could be if you're flying
in the clouds and you completely lost
your GPS and now that you know about
this area you can go around this
airspace if you need to before we end
today's lesson I do want to briefly
mention another set of adaptations that
are really handy to know about if you
ever just a little bit more information
when it comes to Something in aviation
the FAA has got your back
oh yeah just got punched twice
thank you I'm just kidding they really
do in this case if you need more
information on a specific subject the
FAA actually writes special articles
that are designed to clarify a lot of
stuff that you find in the regulations
and other Publications these are called
advisory circulars and if you search the
faa's website what you'll find is that
they actually have a bunch of these
things and it's kind of cool how they do
this because they actually follow a very
similar numbering system that the
regulations do and that makes it way
easier to find the topics that you might
need a little bit more information on as
you can see topics about Airmen and the
certification of Airmen are in the 60
series just like part 61 of the Federal
Aviation regulations Section 90 here
deals with General operating rules just
like far 91 anyway if you don't see what
you need here you can actually search
for keywords like notems and you can
find them that way too and now I can
click on this and now I can read till my
heart's content about notoms or whatever
else I want to know about not only is
there a ton of information in here but
this thing also May makes great bedtime
reading hey thanks for watching today's
video on the dangers of 5G internet oh
that's not what this video is about yeah
I don't really know if that's a 5G Tower
or not so don't go spreading that around
but it does make you wonder doesn't it
in my next video we're going to be
talking about physiological stuff and no
that's not a poop joke it's stuff that
you actually need to know as a pilot and
when that video is done I'll put it
right here I'll see you over there
[Music]
foreign